so welcome to this video against master
Dantas must still don't us sounds like a
dinosaur in a way on Bogut and trash
variation of the French let's see
probably the squeem d5 line coming up
with cd4 ed 525 but let's see what he's
doing like also has Knight f6 on knight
c6 available taking quite some time here
you go in to see 5 I have seen almost
really all Queen musiah but never Quincy
five okay normally the norm was queen to
d6 but they they have recently have been
experimenting with other moves the point
is very often the Queen lens on c7
anyway so not sure that Quincy five vs
is bad in any way maybe I can play I
wonder if I can somehow use this the
Queen on c5 maybe a three before work
and let's try that it's very difficult
for black to to keep the default porn
anyway
Knight takes or maybe I do this first
maybe Bishop takes is actually an option
okay let's retreat here makes it a bit
more tricky if i am to play Bishop to b6
bishop t6 I can play Knights you form
okay or he's not going to cancel on long
isn't he that's what really okay maybe
he can do it it's not totally insane but
it weird that's maybe i can i can delay
this capture really i have this hunch
that he will castle long it looks
totally crazy in a way but maybe ok so
now i'm ready to take the d4 pawn maybe
even 95 first all night in the snide 25
it i can actually take with the Queen at
the end this would be quite nice and
yeah okay but 94 is not not bad at all
okay so um I get 95 now we should d 5
i've got c4 and if he goes route d8 i
can switch the Queen to the Kings side I
was actually intended Queen edge form
but not sure about that Queen edge form
yeah but he does not really have a great
discovered move with this annoyed at
least I don't see it yes this is
designed to protect f7 now I've got
quite some pressure on f7 with and not
only five the bishop won't be three okay
so see for grabbing space maybe allowing
bishop see tool and mostly most
important point is to I believe them
control the d5 square maybe a five maybe
a five is a move
yes but this I thought I can just play
Bishop c3 and he needs to go back or not
didn't and now he can go 95 I'm just an
idiot this is idiotic simply and I was
just thinking 95 95 is not a problem
that is a problem how silly is that
yeah I bishop on c3 yet to be useful on
the long bag and not to get it exchanged
again this silly knight on d5 on f6 as
it was originally posted great yeah now
white is just suffering here against
this looks of the D file and Bishop f6
and stuff
yeah it's great from a position that was
just better for white I'm down to two a
bad position and I've got one minute on
the clock great ok let's see you to try
to defend this jack yeah not a happy
move perform but I need to do it one
minute Sam ok well at least them it's
not like my positions and my pieces are
badly coordinated it's wow really time
morning takes I can also check with the
Queen I mean if you now exchanges Queens
I'm even better again with three against
two on the queenside okay can't play a
queen bee seven but you should have
three Wow
yeah now while it's just better but this
free against two on the queenside and
we'll have six was more what I expected
okay he has a somewhat strange way to
play the endgame here it seems okay a
former b5 can get go here this is an
additional problem this g five moves i
sir simply a bit strange check yum and i
only got 40 seconds but this I think
should be should be doable if he pushes
to e4 them this I need to do first b6
get this get this back
cannot go leave for mini can but then I
have king deform can actually try to
provoke that
do I get to the e5 pawn I'm not quite
sure yet okay I'll just going to attack
and take it then the kingside pawns are
of course the problem I'm going to go
over and pick them up check check select
all Turkish angle check check just not
constant much time but it can can be
decisive it at one moment while we
totally screwed up the same game from
from being just better to worse in a
couple of moves yeah yeah well okay here
you absolutely cannot do what you did to
take this is this is simply not good and
he SMS just a very comfortable position
here with the with the two two bishops
we should be seven and 85 this type of
stuff you need to do just keep the keep
tonight only five and I mean this is not
totally terrible for white but it's just
worse I mean the computer wants to play
b6 yeah this is also a good move yeah
that's a good move trying to make it
difficult for me to play c5 and black
has this idea is to play a five and at
some point even g5 you need to undermine
this and I it's not exchange it after
the exchange
yea yea even blundered c4 Wow can take
on c4 here okay so I needed to take he
actually I meant business is this is now
I'm starting to be okay for white again
just because I've got three points
against two and potentially the slightly
better Bishop as there's something on
light squares but black but it's now
that's not the main point come actually
probably have just about equal okay well
25 was a blunder just giving and can
just take that without any problems but
exchanging now why this is what is
really better and after g5 I think well
this is this is probably beyond saving
and I didn't even play it right in the
computers on plus 2 with Bishop f3m yeah
this is even easier of course yeah the
problem is it's simply like that if you
go here this is just a winning king and
porn endgame very easy and he has no way
to avoid it yeah okay well this is much
easier I was just thinking I'm get to
get the king over and win this Bishop
endgame this is also will win but it's
it's more difficult check or let's say
longer it's not like it's tough to play
but it just takes longer and here should
see 45 is the right plane I was losing a
bit of time only here getting back on
track this is just winning yeah he
completely completely killed himself
here from a good position the main point
of course was all my main problem was of
course that i played this this
astonishingly bad move overlooking 95 if
i play let's say this for
example this is just a simple and good
then why this an excellent shape I just
need to to be a 2 BM observant for this
one moment and avoid 95 and this is just
nice i mean this is controlling
important squares and I've got this
pressure on age 7 Bishop can go here can
go here only 3 is just very comfortable
and from a position that is probably
relatively clearly better for white I
was screwing this up to this to this
catalog position okay thanks for
watching